okay hey guys it's early it's 9:16 a.m.
I woke up at like 5:00 this morning went
to Starbucks productive day already I'm
gonna play this guy because he's a
top-rated player seeking the game and
okay let's play in English having played
in English in a while at least online
it's my main opening for for many years
and will have a will have a huge IDI I
usually play this position for the black
pieces okay so some semi Slav let's play
let's play for mix it up a little bit I
played this line last year in Australia
my opponent played Bishop to b4 check
and then I played Knight c3 this should
be seven looks kind of passive let's
just continue developing
if there's anyone in the chat let me
know if things look okay I forgot to do
an audio test but I hope the sound is ok
ok let's play Bishop to e3
ok hello to people hello pique line big
Baba jewel rubs mug something something
let's castle yeah let's castle hey it's
a sub so you big sub super say on 99
thanks for the sub make that slightly
smaller so usually when black players
might be d7 the plan is to take and then
after it Bishop takes bring the other
Knight to f6 so I would like to play
Knight g3 just to avoid trades because I
have more space that's very likely black
will play c5 yeah P six blocks preparing
this in this so maybe I'll play like b3
in Bishop b2 looks solid
black might equalize like very soon
let's see five let's play Queenie - this
is a rapid game eight minutes no
increment my rook should be on d1 yeah
my rooks belong on d1 and e1 rook e1
first there's also a 95 in this position
maybe I'll play 95 first so if you take
so I was gonna say that my pawn is nice
on e5 and maybe I'll continue soon with
that for I guess ok he'll probably go
back to d7
I would like to attack like queen g4
possibilities then they take c5
so maybe rook e1 followed by queen g4
there's also not h5 immediately maybe 9
h5 right away g 6g 6 v f6 let's do it
there is some sneaky threat for lack to
fly Queen c6 and mate but when I play
Queen g4 it defends g2 okay so I'm
assuming black just wants to play this
second throwing
G for so if he plays g6 I might just
take an efficient f6 or mission f8 i can
play Knight f6 takes takes 9 f6 he's
probably gonna play a King h8 and you
have to manage my time this is a fun
position though I want to thank for
longer and the throw-in f4 first I
didn't see what to do after a night of
16 shades
point I would probably like to play a 5
f6
if I get the chance or maybe even
somehow rook lifts over
this feels wrong but I'm gonna play
rookie one first because there's no like
discovered attacks against us bishop
there's a Knight takes e5 i taketh
bishop in his queen and then g7 pawn and
meanwhile I just want to play rook e3
roof g3 and I feel like black is
relatively restricted because there's
very little counter play G 2 is always
defended and very soon I'll flavor of g3
defending more and attacking more
and well it's gonna have a lot more
attackers than black has defender is on
the Kings side what is Rick c8 seems
like a nothing move considering this
but then Queen c7 let's start with this
so I'm threatening Knight takes g7 if g6
Bishop takes g6 pawn takes G 6 Queen
takes g6 and maid is coming and what
else does black do moves like f5 never
aware because I own pissant as bishop
supports I do not listen to kpop I
barely know what k-pop is I think the K
stands for Korean so that's pretty much
all I know people saying good morning
pop arg1 saying good afternoon means
he's probably in Europe so I'm slightly
down on time but I have a good position
look c-7 trying to understand work c7 I
can just take on g7 if I 5-iron passant
life is good
okay now how he just resigns that was
nice yeah of course like any night move
is coming I think I was gonna take on u6
threatening both rooks and threatening
mates
yeah that was a nice game I was not
expecting to just have such an easy
conversion there well it was an opening
that I think is tricky enough like e4
because most people will expect like III
or 9 f 3e 4 is one of these like very
sharp more were kind of theoretical
battles where the point is that after a
bishop to be for the main line would be
Bishop T to Queen takes T for Bishop
takes before Queen takes e4 and I think
they call this some marshal gambit yeah
the Marshall cabinets which there's a
few marshal Cabot's there's a marshal
gambit for black this time like sky
emitting a pawn I think there should be
two and ninety two are both moves and
then there's a crazy line like after the
after 92 96 yeah the main move here is
Bishop f8 just such a random move but
pointies King can't take on f8 because
Queen d8 is mate meanwhile G sevens
attacks so I don't think I would have
gone into any of this I was just
planning to play a knight c3 and there
was a Carlsen game from the World
Championship Carlsen Anand which somehow
Carlsen one like it was a relatively
equal position but Carlsen hold the
Carlsen
I'm not gonna go through the whole thing
but I just want to see the date because
it was around this time of year that was
November 15th so we're approaching the
what the five year anniversary of this
game anyway anything more to say about
that game uh it was a nice attacking
game like the combination of the the
bishops and the Knights like everything
had potential to attack and the fact
that White has a bit more space and all
the minor pieces are still on the board
makes it a bit more difficult for black
and this 95 move eventually I think was
important maybe I shouldn't take my
black should just leave the tension play
something like rookie AIDS
put something on f8 I was probably gonna
play rookie one I was fantasizing about
ideas of Knight takes f7 and then
winning e6 maybe buck and just play
Bishop by fate's and be safe I think
when the pawn lands on e5 this is big
trouble for black because it's just a
free attack I wanted to do this because
if black takes and I'm really happy if
black doesn't take and there's King h8
this is where I didn't see what to do
stockfish have anything sawfish is stuck
okay if 9 th 5 is the best move then I
didn't really accomplish anything but
okay I was happy with that 4 and then
the rest of the game was just yeah it
felt pretty simple anyway I'm not gonna
stay around for long